so the finale is oh great I love the
finale what do you what do you think
fans will think when it ends season one
I hope they're gonna go when are they
gonna release the second season that
we're shooting right now that's what I
was going to say I can't say more it's
far too vulnerable and it's it's so easy
to drop a little hint
um I'm not gonna sure
wetter uh right exactly I definitely
want to know what is it actually like
you've gotten to work on so many cool
properties if you had told yourself
years ago what you'd be doing this year
or last year what would you you know
what I mean I do know
um I try not to ask that question
because
I move I move with the next job all the
time and I never stop to think
like what's gonna happen in the next
five years it's more I stop and I think
did I just do a doom right did June 2
did this just happen did I just do is
silo doing well and then I have to go on
again I can't stop there for too long
but it comes I mean it's a I'm very
lucky right now I actually I just
realized I was gonna ask you about
something else but I've just realized I
heard you and Tim Miller might do
something called best served cold do you
know of it I I do have you read Jeremy
cornbrey's books so do you think that's
that do you think that project is going
to happen
yes
oh for real yeah yeah we're just talking
about casting and we wands around and
yeah I'm very very excited we'll see now
with with strikes and everything that's
happening sure
um but everything will happen in its own
time last thing for you this movie is
incredible what are you most I mean I
love this movie it's the fastest two
hour 30 minute film you're gonna see
what are you most excited for audiences
to see
do you know I in a mission film it's
never one moment it is like this is a
Mission Impossible film on crack
that is literally it you think you've
seen it all you just haven't no you're
100 right there's nothing there's you
think there's one stunned because you've
maybe seen it on a trailer they're about
I mean you'll be blown away